Where we left off
in the last video,
we had a mature
massive star, a star
that had started
forming a core of iron.
It has enormous pressure,
enormous inward pressure
on this core.
Because as we form heavier and
heavier elements in the core,
the core gets denser
and denser and denser.
And so we keep fusing more
and more elements into iron.
This iron core becomes
more and more massive, more
and more dense.
It's squeezing in on itself.
And it's not fusing.
That is not exothermic anymore.
If iron were to fuse,
it would not even
be an exothermic process.
It would require energy.
So it wouldn't be
even something that
could be helped to fend off
this squeezing, to fend off
this increasing
density of the core.
So we have this iron
here, and it just
gets more and more massive,
more and more dense.
And so at some mass, already
a reasonably high mass,
the only thing that's keeping
this from just completely
collapsing is-- we could call
it electron degeneracy pressure.
So let me write this here,
electron degeneracy pressure.
And all this means is we have
all of these iron atoms getting
really, really, really
close to each other.
And the only thing that keeps it
from collapsing at this earlier
stage, the only thing that keeps
it from collapsing altogether,
is that they have
these electrons.
You have these
electrons, and these
are being squeezed
together, now.
I mean, we're talking about
unbelievably dense states
of matter.
And electron degeneracy
pressure is, essentially--
it's saying these
electrons don't
want to be in the same
place at the same time.
I won't go into the
quantum mechanics of it.
But they cannot be squeezed
into each other any more.
So that, at least
temporarily, holds this thing
from collapsing even further.
And in the case of
a less massive star,
in the case of a
white dwarf, that's
how a white dwarf actually
maintains its shape, because
of the electron
degeneracy pressure.
But as this iron core gets
even more massive, more dense,
and we get more and more
gravitational pressure--
so this is our core, now--
even more gravitational
pressure, eventually even
this electron degeneracy--
I guess we could call
it force, or pressure,
this outward pressure,
this thing that keeps it
from collapsing--
even that gives in.
And then we have something
called electron capture,
which is essentially
the electrons
get captured by
protons in the nucleus.
They start collapsing
into the nucleuses.
It's kind of the opposite of
beta negative decay, where
you have the electrons
get captured,
protons get turned
into neutrons.
You have neutrinos
being released.
But you can imagine an
enormous amount of energy
is also being released.
So this is kind of a
temporary-- and then
all of a sudden, this collapses.
This collapses even more
until all you have--
and all the protons are
turning into neutrons.
Because they're
capturing electrons.
So what you eventually
have is this entire core
is collapsing into a
dense ball of neutrons.
You can kind of view
them as just one
really, really,
really, really, really
massive atom because it's
just a dense ball of neutrons.
At the same time, when
this collapse happens,
you have an enormous
amount of energy
being released in the
form of neutrinos.
Did I say that neutrons
are being released?
No, no, no, the electrons are
being captured by the protons,
protons turning into
neutrons-- this dense ball
of neutrons right here--
and in the process,
neutrinos get released,
these fundamental particles.
We won't go into
the details here.
But it's an enormous
amount of energy.
And this actually is
not really, really well
understood, of all
of the dynamics here.
Because at the same time that
this iron core is undergoing
through this-- at
first it kind of pauses
due to the electron
degeneracy pressure.
And then it finally gives
in because it's so massive.
And then it collapses into
this dense ball of neutrons.
But when it does it, all
of this energy's released.
And it's not clear how-- because
it has to be a lot of energy.
Because remember, this
is a massive star.
So you have a lot of mass
in this area over here.
But it's so much energy that
it causes the rest of the star
to explode outward in an
unbelievable, I guess,
unbelievably bright or
energetic explosion.
And that's called a supernova.
And the reason why
it's called nova,
it comes from, I
believe-- I'm not
an expert here--
Latin for "new."
And the first time
people observed a nova,
they thought it was a new star.
Because all of a
sudden, something
they didn't see before,
all of a sudden,
it looks like a star appeared.
Because maybe it
wasn't bright enough
for us to observe it before.
But then when the nova occurred,
it did become bright enough.
So it comes from
the idea of new.
But a supernova is when you
have a pretty massive star's
core collapsing.
And that energy
is being released
to explode the rest of the star
out at unbelievable velocities.
And just to kind of fathom
the amount of energy that's
being released in
a supernova, it
can temporarily outshine
an entire galaxy.
And in a galaxy, we're
talking about hundreds
of billions of stars.
Or another way to
think about it,
in that very short
period of time,
it can release as much
energy as the sun will
in its entire lifetime.
So these are unbelievably
energetic events.
And so you actually
have the material
that's not in the core
being shot out of the star
at appreciable percentages
of the actual speed of light.
So we're talking about things
being shot out at up to 10%
of the speed of light.
Now, that's 30,000
kilometers per second.
That's almost circumnavigating
the earth every second.
So that's, I mean, this is
unbelievably energetic events
that we're talking about here.
And so if the original star
was-- and these are rough
estimates.
People don't have kind
of a hard limit here.
If the original star
approximately 9 to 20 times
the mass of the sun,
then it will supernova.
And the core will turn into
what's called a neutron star.
This is a neutron
star, which you
can imagine is just
this dense ball.
It's this dense
ball of neutrons.
And just to give
you a sense of it,
it'll be something about maybe
two times the mass of the sun,
give or take one and a half
to three times the mass
of the sun.
So this is one and a
half to three times
the mass of the sun
in a volume that
has a diameter of about
10-- on the order of tens
of kilometers.
So it's roughly the size of a
city, in a diameter of a city.
So this is unbelievably
dense, diameter of a city.
I mean, we know how
much larger the sun
is relative to the Earth.
And we know how much larger the
Earth is relative to a city.
But this is something
large-- more mass
than the sun being
squeezed into the density,
or into the size of a city,
so unbelievably dense.
Now if the original star
is even more massive,
if it's more than 20
times the sun-- so
let me write it over here.
Let me scroll up.
If it's greater than
20 times the sun,
then even the neutron degeneracy
pressure, even the pressure,
even the neutrons' inability to
squeeze further will give up.
And it'll turn
into a black hole.
And that's-- and I could
do many videos on that.
And that's actually an open
area of research, still,
on exactly what's going
on inside of a black hole.
But then you turn
into a black hole,
where essentially
all of the mass
gets condensed into an
infinitely small and dense
point, so something
unbelievably hard to imagine.
And just to give
you a sense of it,
so this will be more mass
then even three times the mass
of the sun.
So we're talking about an
incredibly high amount of mass.
Just to kind of
visualize things,
here is actually a
remnant of a supernova.
This is the Crab Nebula.
This is, right here,
is the Crab Nebula.
And it's about 6,500
light years away.
So it's still, from
a galactic scale--
if you think of our galaxy
as being 100,000 light years
in diameter-- it's still not
too far from us on those scales.
But it's an enormous distance.
The closest star to us
is four light years away.
And it would take Voyager
travelling at 60,000 kilometers
an hour, 80,000
years to get there.
So this is a very, very--
that's only four light years.
Now this is 6,500 light years.
But this supernova,
it's believed
happened 1,000 years
ago, right at the center.
And so at the center here, we
should have a neutron star.
And this cloud, the shock
wave that you see here,
this is still the
material traveling
outward from that
supernova over 1,000 years.
This shock wave, or the diameter
of this sphere of material,
is six light years.
So we could say this distance
right here is six light years.
So this is an enormously
big shock wave cloud.
And actually, we believe
that our solar system started
to form, started to condense
because of a shock wave created
by a supernova
relatively near to us.
And just to answer
another question that
was kind of jumping
up, probably,
in the last video-- and this is
still not really, really well
understood.
We talk about how elements
up to iron, or maybe nickel,
can be formed inside of
the cores of massive stars.
So you could imagine
when the star explodes,
a lot of that material is
released into the universe.
And so that's why we have
a lot of these materials
in our own bodies.
In fact, we could not exist if
these heavier elements were not
formed inside of the cores of
primitive stars, stars that
have supernova-ed
a long time ago.
Now the question is, how do
these heavier elements form?
How do we get all of this other
stuff on the periodic table?
How do we get all these
other heavier elements?
And they're formed during
the supernova itself.
It's so energetic.
You have all sorts of particles
streaming out and streaming in,
streaming out because of
the force of the shock wave,
streaming in because
of the gravity.
But you have all sorts of
kind of a mishmash of elements
forming.
And that's actually
where you have
your heavier elements forming.
And because-- and I'll talk more
about this in future videos--
most of the uranium,
or actually,
all of uranium on
Earth right now,
must have been formed in some
type of a supernova explosion,
at least based on our
current understanding.
And it looks to be about
4.6 billion years old.
So given that it looks to be
about 4.6 billion years old,
based on how fast it's decayed--
and I'll do a whole video
on that-- that's why we think
that our solar system was first
formed from some type
of supernova explosion.
Because that uranium
would have been
formed right at about the
birth of our solar system.
Anyway, hopefully, you
found that interesting.
This is a fascinating picture.
And if you go to Wikipedia
and look up the Crab Nebula,
keep clicking on the image.
And eventually you'll
get a zoomed in picture.
And that's just kind of
even more mind blowing.
Because you could see all the
intricacy in this actual photo.